oui vous ne rêvez pas nous sommes bien
sûr le jeu plus rageant de la planète
il ya du monde c'est squeeze et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur un bon
gros elle.w de bien gras comme dirait
jojo alors ouais bon bah voilà ça fait
un peu retour aux sources
on va dire en quelque sorte mais un
homme est si une partie acquis et merde
ah bah voilà bon bah écoutez en
souhaitant une partie avec les bons j'ai
un peu la flemme de quitter je vais pas
vous mentir de recommencer alors que ça
fait vingt mille ans qu'est ce que je
fais ça fait vraiment temps que j'ai pas
joué alors écoutez dans cette vidéo déjà
je tiens particulièrement à remercier
mes cent cinquante six mille abonnés je
crois j'ai pas pu faire une vidéo ou des
vidéos spécial 150000 parce que j'étais
au cap d'agde avec florent vous avez
bien vu la vidéo des vacances j'étais au
café avec lui et à et pourquoi de
sincère c'est un truc collard
extraordinaire encore une fois bon vous
devez vous dire qu'on se répète et c'est
aussi jeudi à chaque fois qu'on se
répète mais d'un côté c'est la vérité
c'est quelque chose de dingue de voilà
enfin je pense que plus vous rencontre
mais des fois personnes en tout cas pour
ma part j'ai des grosses prises de
conscience je me dis tu aimes les quatre
ans compte que tu as quand même que tu
as quand même plus de 150000 personnes
qui te suivent enfin enfin c'est
exceptionnel c'est incroyable et si l'on
écouté je suis plutôt content de voir
petit ce prêt de voir tu les vidéos
comme la japan expo les vidéos des
vacances plaisent parce que c'est des
vidéos qui demande beaucoup beaucoup de
temps pour le montage je vais pas vous
mentir ça demande quand même assez de
temps sachant qu'il faut à tout tourne
et qu'ensuite il faut faire le tri entre
les images dit servent à rien les images
qu'ils savaient quelque chose et c est à
chaque fois je prends un gros plaisir à
faire le montage et puis bah quand je
vois que ça plaît en plus derrière aux
gens j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
parfait voilà tout je me fait tirer
dessus à mais ce jeu mais bordel
j'en ai marre voilà tu côtoies est-ce
que tu coûteux il était caché dans le
peloton
mais arrête avec ton la stand up mais
c'est pas possible quoi les gens les
hommes femmes bref alors sinon je
voulais vous dire que je vais partir
donc de nouveau en vacances du 3 août
jusqu'au 22 août dont une cette fois ci
évidemment vu que c'est quand même bien
plus long que la petite semaine au cap
avec flanc on va on va mettre un système
en place c'est à dire que bon je vais
vous laisser le chanteur vous présenter
ce système est oui
l'incroyable chanteur du tube oh mon
dieu qu'est ce que tu peux
[Musique]
voilà vous alors
station par le chanteur du hit 2012 aura
plus en tout cas voilà c'est à dire je
me suis dit que je veux pas vous laisser
vraiment sans vidéo quoi j'ai vraiment
envie de laisser le petit vidéo donc
vous aurez du max payne et d'autres
vidéos comme papa du max payne des
vidéos que je fais en dehors du locle et
donc voilà normalement tout a été dit
j'ai aussi à cette raison je les ferai
en différé le tissu de sa pépite schumi
et si non vous ne rêvez pas
je suis bel et bien malade parce que
hors jolie quand vous sortez le soir
messieurs dames
je vous conseille de préparer un sweat
dans votre sac vous sur votre bras parce
que ça sert à voir rentrer quand il fait
aussi froid ça fait mal au cul ça fait
mal au cul et sa procureur mais commence
à me casser le cul la mouette là ohlala
mais sincèrement ou quoi dans mes colocs
six jours c'est rageant sincèrement ça
ne changera jamais le jeu plus rageant
de tous les temps est parmi nous ce soir
et alors on va essayer de faire un truc
potable non ils vont voler le truc et
vont jouer le truc j'en ai marre en
alors ils non mais non mais non mais oh
là là mon dieu c'est afld dans sa salle
oms les gens rendez vous compte deezer
qu'on avait tous passés sur call of on
les aurait passé sur d'autres jeux en
faisant le solo de jeu par exemple ou
quoi mais imaginez imaginez le temps
gagné imaginez sincèrement jusque là je
trouve que la mode call of commence un
petit peu à partir avant je vais pas
vous il ya un mec là
évidemment le l'ac thann je vais pas
vous mentir j'ai l'impression que tout
ça se
c'est banni un peu on va dire en quelque
sorte s'évanouit se ralentit un petit
peu que voilà tout le monde en a un
petit peu marre de voir toujours les
mêmes choses même les vidéos commentées
sur call of duty
d'ailleurs à mes poumons
non ça olalalala puis voilà enfin tout
le monde cela s'est un petit peu de le
dire je ne suis pas pourquoi joe style
peur c'est une bonne question pourquoi
excusez moi pardon
pourquoi juste la peur alors j'aime bah
oui parce qu'un connard en or fine
quelle question non alors j'essaie de
faire un truc potable made in japan
ah ah j'en ai marre en plus de vous
péter les oreilles s'user moi les gens
mais voilà les gens se lassent un petit
peu de toujours voir ma les quads fluide
et simple filet triplé quoi laisser
catch up etc
voilà ça tout ça ça tombe un peu et puis
on en a la preuve puisque quand on fait
des vidéos sur autre chose que call of
au final ça marche tout aussi bien bon
sauf cas sauf ceux qui découvrent un peu
comme la force armée aura toujours une
certaine partie de lui qu'il découvre
que l'offre bon même si ça se fait rare
quand même ces gens là mais voilà tout
le monde en a un petit peu marre chacun
joue dans son coin colloque qu'on n'a
pas forcément envie de jouer à autre
chose
finir un jeu de faire le saut d'un jeu
mais mais ouais moi personnellement pour
ma part je trouve que voilà ça dit ça en
devient qu'avant et que heureusement
pour eux c'est black ops de sera le
dernier call of parce que sincèrement
enfin avant les consoles next gen
parce que sincèrement mais regardez-moi
ce mec quoi parce que sincèrement voilà
on atteint les limites de tout ça bon on
va c'est de lui mettre une part dans la
gueule boom alors john hamm attendez
attendez attendez vous faire tripoter un
truc potable ou pas d'ailleurs
mais non mais non mais non mais c'était
non mais sincèrement j'en ai marre mais
là tu broc le spawn bordel donc bon
voilà en tout cas j'espère que lui
peut-il être fait sur max payne déjà je
m'excuse du fait que les épisodes met
autant de temps à sortir mais voilà pour
x raisons je n'ai pas pu sortir beaucoup
d'épisodes heures beaucoup devaient de
vidéo en général voudrait voir marquer
bon voilà on a chacun nos problèmes
comme je l'avais dit sur twitter
d'ailleurs allé me suis sur twitter
c'est vraiment important c'est dans la
description
ça vous en apprend beaucoup sur l'humeur
de youtube heures sur qu'est ce qui se
passe dans leur vie pourquoi ils font ça
ou ça vous ça pour quoi ils parlent vrai
mais toi mais [ __ ] mais ce mec est
insupportable quoi donc je vous
conseille d'aller me susurre tout cas le
lien dans la description et puis même
coutteure c'est convivial c'est sais
c'est pas comme ce connard de merde par
exemple mais qu'est ce que c'est à
samedi les fesses à ça brûle assez bon
ça va mieux
non mais sincèrement c'est horrible ce
colloque
mais quinze n'est qu'à mes thèses n'est
jamais les caennais qaeda et voilà le
make up a d'ailleurs c'est sdk qui est
le last m mais sincèrement les gens il
ya un moment
call of tout le monde sait turc une
belle vue du sud ou à l'annoncé pas ce
qu'il fait là voilà lille attend il va
m'avoir puisse ce qu'on vous allez voir
les regardez moi ça non mais sincèrement
bref j'arrête de rage est un petit peu
mais bon là j'ai l'impression que les
gens d'ailleurs en ce moment les
youtuber se mettent à faire de plus en
plus de vidéos en a une par jour pour la
chaîne secondaire d'ailleurs de benoît
2009 franchement vous avez l'air de
suivre et d'aimer ça et puis c'est pas
plus mal ça vous permet au moins d'avoir
beaucoup de contenu et de choisir le
contenu de cailloux tube heures vous
voulez suivre
bon après si tous les tubes chiites ou
l'est youtuber se met à faire ça c'est
clair que ça à vis de partir en couille
puisqu'il y aura vraiment énormément des
vidéos pour énormément de youtube heures
donc je pense que vous devez être un peu
saoul et il commence à me saouler
je ne marche pas et la grenade à elle
m'aurait dessus jurica non mais thèse
n'est qu'à mes mecs mais non mais
sérieux coup sincèrement sincèrement il
ya un moment fort à t2 pas d'utiliser
les armes les plus faciles du jeu est de
trouver ça trop lol ah j'en étais sûr qu
il aime avoir c'est qu'on va sortir
l'espace 12 madeleine et en lui il n'y a
pas de compteur étonnante la parra qui
sert à rien c'est sûr non banon banal
puisqu'il conclut spawn
mais tout ça donc bien changé enfin bon
à le famas on retrouve une très belle
arme je vraiment comme une merde mais
sincèrement je cours alors qu'un nez
juste là au nom la volée à une seconde
près donc bon voilà écouter en tout cas
youtube évolué mine de rien et puis bon
voilà ce que je trouve ça dommage c'est
que parfois on reçoit des demandes de
gens qui veulent qu'on leur fasse de la
pub et c'est déjà sachez qu'on n'est pas
là pour faire de la pub mais pour lancer
les gens même si pourtant ou lancent
chacun région regarder warteck m'a lancé
moi j'ai lancé fait sauf un chacal ans
un peu un peu tout le monde
mais voilà que les gens nous demandent
de la pub qui disent qu'il faut les
choses extraordinaires alors pour quand
on va sur leur chaîne on nous trouve que
du colloque fait dès qu'ils filent et
c'est trop lol bon voilà c'est pas en
faisant ça les gens que vous percevrez
sincèrement et puis surtout que
maintenant ça devient très très dur de
percer sur youtube où on est tous
d'accord pour le dire
à moins d'être pistonné d'être un peu
lancé par quelqu'un ça devient dur mais
c'est pas en faisant du call of call of
call of call of que vous serez lancé et
puis voilà faut aussi trouver le petit
truc original par exemple comme du guide
x qui fait que tout le monde adhère et
que tout le monde aime ça voilà en tout
cas j'espère que cet utilitaire vous
aura plu c'était plus une vidéo en mode
pause et je ne sais pas on parle de tout
et de rien même si ce [ __ ] de colas
fait toujours aussi radieux je vais
mettre un suppôt parce que j'ai trouvé
qu vérité enfin bon voilà on se retrouve
bientôt à une prochaine vidéo tu as tout
le monde bat et bientôt pis
debout je pète web où et n'importe quoi
on invite pain sur la planche
pourquoi tu vises tout de suite les
couilles
pourquoi
[Musique]